i learned that there's still a ton that
i need to improve on uh there really is
uh i made a lot a lot of plays having
kind of off script this year but there
was times where i try to make those
plays happen in instead of just taking
the easy completion for a first down and
so i have to keep finding that line
whenever i want to try to make the big
play happen and when i want to just take
the easy completion move the change keep
the offense on the field keep rolling
down the field and that's stuff that i
have to keep working on every single
year and that scheme of that really
opened my eyes to that
2018 nfl mvp patrick mahomes on how he's
trying to get better you know chris is
explaining it i'm thinking no no no
don't don't take the easy completion we
want to see the spectacular play right
throw the ball down the field do the no
look pass throw it with your left hand
do whatever you have to do give us a
highlight right there's no highlights
that come out of the dink and dunk no
but i i understand the point and and i
can't imagine the guy actually being
better but think about that that was his
first season as a starter and now he's
working his butt off to get better who
knows where this guy's ceiling is no the
ceiling is is is i mean really when he
if he reaches his ultimate ultimate
potential he's a guy that can be in the
conversation for one of the greatest
quarterbacks ever i mean yes it's that
type of talent the kid has i mean great
demeanor unfazed by big moments good
athlete you know one of the most
explosive dynamic arms we've ever seen
in football and we've only seen him for
one year but we already know that
because he made throws last year that
nobody in the history of the sport has
ever made and mike i know you and i
talked about this during the season last
year
man did he leave a lot of plays on the
field and i'm not trying to be
disrespectful into that in any way
because he made so many plays that other
quarterbacks couldn't make but there was
a number of slam dunk plays wide open
people down the middle of the field
where i think in year two with him being
a little more comfortable seeing
defenses a little bit better uh that he
will hit some of the throws that i saw
him miss last year to where yeah i look
at it and just go i have a hard time
believing this guy is not going to be at
the top of just about every statistical
category once again because of the
chief's offense and because of his
talent and this year could arguably be
the most challenging of his career
because this is the first opportunity
for defenses to implement
everything they've learned by studying
carefully everything he did last year a
year ago they really didn't know what to
expect now they do and now we see this
all the time anytime the next big thing
hits the nfl defenses become determined
to try to counter it so he's got to stay
a step ahead of them and and that may
not be the easiest thing to do and it's
going to get easier as more and more
film is accumulated of what defenses are
doing and of what he's doing but this is
going to be his first big test because
we don't know what defenses have up
their sleeves when they're going to face
patrol homes this year so can he counter
that can andy reid help him through that
and help him continue toward that
ceiling that's going to be the big
challenge and that's why i won't be
surprised if there is a step back this
year as he kind of regroups and learns
how to get past whatever defenses are
doing to neutralize his skills well it's
certainly a valid point and i think it's
very real and you know added to that
fact right i mean we don't expect tyree
kill to be there so that's going to make
it even more challenging guys like sammy
watkins who are being sammy watkins
being paid 16 million dollars a year
like a number one receiver in the nfl he
needs to kind of show his worth this
year but mike going back to mahomes like
spot on i mean hey their teams are going
to go back especially the afc west teams
and they're going to start to compile a
book a little bit you know most division
teams spend a week maybe a little more
on their other division rivals at some
point during the off-season and have a
little base game plan or thoughts that
they look back at last year and think oh
we need to do this this year one thing i
think for sure and we saw new england do
this and you still can't stop him all
the way is stop him from getting out of
the pocket and especially running right
his statistics getting out of the pocket
and especially to the right side were
through the roof last year he was
basically unstoppable when that happened
and you can think of a number of plays
here's one right here against the
patriots you know what though they had a
guy there grabbing his jersey because
they had a rover spying him he made a
bad interception you know so it's going
to be about that and his adjustment mike
you're exactly right and he's going to
have to have some moves to counter some
of the things that uh he routinely did
last year
if you're in new england still like you
were seven years ago and bill belichick
comes to you and says all right sims
you've watched the film what can we do
to further
keep patrick mahomes from being the guy
that he is when everything is working
for him yeah i i think the big i of
course would start with that not getting
out of the pocket right you know the
second thing i would do you know just as
far as
i would make mahomes
you know make me believe that he's
willing to throw check downs and the
shorter passes and execute that way uh
that would probably be another thing i
would look at because he does have such
an aggressive nature andy reed has such
an aggressive nature as a play caller so
that would be maybe one other aspect if
i didn't have a team that i felt like
could man
by kansas city chiefs man-to-man yeah i
would play deep zones a little bit like
remember we saw the denver broncos do
and the los angeles chargers do who gave
them some trouble right late in the
season really backed off and just said
we don't trust andy reid or patrick
mahomes that you'll take the
conservative approach and beat us that
way and i think that'll be part of the
book on beating the chiefs in my homes
here going forward a little bit
i mean the problem is like with blitzing
and whatnot he's so good at getting away
from pressure and that's when everything
starts to break down is when he seems to
be at his best so you almost do have to
have a very controlled systematic
approach where you force him to be
patient because eventually he will get
impatient
as you force him to be patient and maybe
he will throw the ball that's screwed
i'm throwing it deep right when he
shouldn't but he just wants to and i
think he's going to have to engineer
that out of his nature and maybe a year
or two of seeing defenses force him to
do it is one of the but can what a
wasted talent chris of all we're doing
is seeing checkdowns i don't want to see
checked out i know me neither but you
know it's again he's got to just bring
it to a part of his game like we talk
about with a carson wentz or cam newton
can they slide can they do that and add
that to their game yeah his patience and
an ability to go you know what i'll take
the short completion i'll get the big
play later that is something that's
going to test him and he's probably
hasn't been tested in that area before
it'd be fun to watch
more from adam gase's press conference
when pft live continues
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports